Ces ondes à haute amplitude sont appelées les ondes delta.
Ne pas atteindre notre besoin en sommeil
freine notre capacité d'apprentissage
et la régénération de nos cellules et de notre corps.
Le sommeil profond transfère toutes nos interactions
vécues tout au long de la journée
vers la mémoire à long terme et nos personnalités.
En vieillissant,
ces ondes delta réparatrices tendent à disparaître.
Donc, dans un sens, le sommeil profond et les ondes delta
sont finalement un repère en termes de jeunesse biologique.
Évidemment, j'ai moi-même cherché à avoir plus de sommeil profond
et j'ai testé presque tous les gadgets, les trucs, les appareils et astuces,
pour les consommateurs, les cliniques,
vous voyez le genre.
J'ai beaucoup appris et j'ai découvert que j'avais besoin, comme beaucoup,
de huit heures de sommeil.
J'ai même modifié les composantes de mon cycle circadien
en changeant de repas, d'exercices physiques et mon exposition à la lumière
mais je ne trouvais pas comment avoir un sommeil plus profond.
Jusqu'à ce que je rencontre le Dr Dmitry Gerashchenko
de la Harvard Medical School.
Dmitry m'a parlé d'une découverte parmi la communauté scientifique
où un laboratoire près de l'Allemagne a montré qu'en jouant certains sons
au bon moment pendant le sommeil de la personne,
il était possible de le rendre plus profond et plus efficace.
En plus, ce laboratoire a montré
qu'ils pouvaient améliorer la performance de leur mémoire du jour suivant
avec ce même son.
Dmitry et moi avons collaboré
et avons commencé à travailler sur le développement de cette technologie.
Avec nos collaborateurs de recherche au laboratoire de Pennsylvanie,
nous avons créé des expériences pour valider notre système.
Depuis, nous avons reçu des fonds venant de la Fondation nationale pour la science
et de l'Institut national pour la santé
pour développer cette technologie de stimulation du sommeil profond.
Voici son fonctionnement.
Des candidats sont venus
et nous leur avons donné quelques appareils.
En voici deux ici-même.
Très tendance.
(Rires)
Lorsque leur état de sommeil profond était détecté,
nous lancions les sons de stimulation du sommeil profond
qui semblaient rendre leur sommeil plus profond.
Voici une démonstration de ce son.
(Sons de vagues répétés)
C'est un peu bizarre, non ?
(Rires)
Ce son est donc sur la même fréquence que vos ondes cérébrales
lorsque vous êtes en sommeil profond.
En réalité, ce son prépare votre esprit
à avoir davantage d'ondes delta réparatrices.
Le lendemain, nous avons questionné les participants
et ils ne se sont pas aperçus que nous avions joué ces sons,
pourtant leur cerveau a répondu en augmentant le nombre d'ondes delta.
Voici un résultat des ondes cérébrales de l'étude que nous avons menée.
Vous voyez en bas ?
C'est le moment où le son a été joué avec la même fréquence que les ondes delta.
Regardez les ondes cérébrales en haut du graphique.
Vous pouvez voir
que le son fait produire au cerveau plus d'ondes delta réparatrices.
Nous avons appris que nous pouvions suivre précisément le sommeil
sans coller des électrodes aux gens
et rendre leur sommeil plus profond.
Nous continuons de développer
un environnement sonore propice et une ambiance de sommeil
afin d'améliorer la qualité du sommeil des gens.
Notre sommeil n'est pas aussi réparateur qu'il devrait l'être
mais peut-être que bientôt
nous pourrons porter de petits appareils
et tirer plus de profit de notre sommeil.
Merci.
(Applaudissement)